does your app deal with sensitive data
do you need to ensure that it's
protected
stay tuned to find out how easily cloud
dlp does this
and much more
[Applause]
throughout this data loss prevention
series we're going to focus on our
fictitious feline walking company
kitty cat walks kitty cat walks pairs
cat owners with local catwalkers via
their online and mobile app
kitty cat walks launched six months ago
and it's rapidly gaining customers
they want to understand more about their
customers both human and feline alike
and they need a way to share and analyze
some custom information like
preferred preferred
walk length or favorite catnip while
protecting sensitive data like addresses
and credit card numbers
while this work would be super hard for
humans it's pretty easy for cloud dlp
not only can cloud dlp automatically
detect addresses and credit card numbers
it has over 120 predefined info types
you can even define your own based on
custom dictionary detectors
or regular expressions so you can
protect things like customer account
numbers
so what sort of data can dlp scan cloud
dlp scans streams of data
structured text files and cloud storage
or data in bigquery and even
images once found and classified
dlp can de-identify the data using
techniques like redaction
masking tokenization date shifting and
more
using the right combination of these
techniques allows you to preserve the
right data and still retain some
referential integrity to collect
important metrics
and make smart business decisions by
adequately de-identifying
data that we don't need for any business
purpose we can minimize the likelihood
of exposure of sensitive customer
information which helps protect our
users
and our business so what would happen if
we didn't adequately de-identify our
data
well if that data fell into the wrong
hands we run the risk of exposing
sensitive information about individuals
which can have some serious privacy
implications
sounds scary but cloud dlp can help
compute and quantify the risk
according to several metrics and it can
publish its findings and summary details
to other systems
for our catwalk app it's clear that
we're collecting personal information
like credit card numbers and addresses
but how do we use dlp to help keep their
customer data safe
stay tuned for the next episode where
we'll cover what is data
[Music]
de-identification